got to get it in here's luca  gets it away it's gone a doncic  dagger  as he was stumbling he somehow got it to  go  was it a three though dave it looked  like his foot was behind the line and he  released it in time but we'll look at  both  we'll see first of all did he get rid of  it in time and was it a three  what a shot he's stumbling i mean the  fact that he made that whether it's a  three or two is remarkable in and of  itself let's see was he behind the line  let's see if he got it off in time watch  the foot oh yeah that's a three and he  got it away in time that's good that's a  win  what a shot  and what a dagger for memphis  i mean falling forward stumbling out of  control he's at the rim when the ball  goes through the net  his momentum carrying him forward as  luca wins it with a three  puts up 29 points 25 in the second half  and a huge  road win for the mavs